to guard him on that step back Martin
gets the ball right back from capella
I'm on the shot clock
they had a couple of young guards get
hurt on them before the season even
started and hardens to the basket and it
goes with very easy with the opposite he
turned the opposite way he normally does
it's wrong legged everything that's
right hard knocks it away one Ryoji may
hit you especially if you play with the
chemical something bigger than a whole
lot wide open as
down marco belinelli is on the right
side of the court you're beyond house
garden to the basket for two more it
just pours it up there with the facts
the first quarter when we come back
he'll be at the line for points 20 and
that's how Bob got fired Bob Hill is
fighting for the land 7 seconds on the
shot clock
[Music]
although are you kidding me
[Applause]
look at this three right here at the top
of the three-point line is 23 feet 9
inches
the woman's church supermo will show you
that he's at least 10 feet behind that
[Music]
hardin picked up on the perimeter got it
is white with a Miss cappella starts a
fast-break look at cappella get up and
down that court and harden with a parade
[Applause]
[Music]
here comes the double-team as Mills
getting done making a difference
James Harden with his fifth
three-pointer of the game nine seconds
down to eight down to seven harden gets
through the scrub and makes two more
[Applause]